This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是 I-Heart 播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及建立恢复力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听 2%。也就是在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO. percent。在 Look Back at it 播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及我们最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.|||在 IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间聚焦于黑人的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一身铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 learn the hard way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有两名男子也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.|||迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 Iheart radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。你好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another episode, new listeners, old listeners. It's so great to have you here to have you back for another topic, one that I am really, really excited for. So today we are going to be discussing comparison and the dangers of comparing ourselves to others, especially in our 20s. I'm sure for many of you who are listening right now, comparison is something that you may have dealt with quite a bit. I am definitely the same. But today we really want to dispel some of the negativity around it and talk about how it's actually a pretty normal human behavior. And there is a lot of psychology and science that explains why it occurs. I think personally comparison can be such an insidious and common cause of insecurity in our 20th.
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another episode, new listeners, old listeners. It's so great to have you here to have you back for another topic, one that I am really, really excited for. So today we are going to be discussing comparison and the dangers of comparing ourselves to others, especially in our 20s. I'm sure for many of you who are listening right now, comparison is something that you may have dealt with quite a bit. I am definitely the same. But today we really want to dispel some of the negativity around it and talk about how it's actually a pretty normal human behavior. And there is a lot of psychology and science that explains why it occurs. I think personally comparison can be such an insidious and common cause of insecurity in our 20th.|||大家好，欢迎回到本节目。欢迎收听新的一期节目，新老听众们。很高兴你们来到这里，听我聊另一个我非常、非常期待的话题。所以今天我们要讨论的是比较，以及将自己与他人进行比较的危害，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候。我相信对于现在正在收听节目的许多人来说，比较可能是你们经常要应对的事情。我绝对也是这样。但今天我们真的想消除一些围绕它的消极情绪，并探讨它其实是一种非常正常的人类行为。有很多心理学和科学可以解释为什么它会发生。我个人认为，在我们的20多岁，比较可能是一个如此隐蔽且常见的缺乏安全感的原因。
and it can also undermine our self-esteem, our ability to focus on ourselves, our self-worth, our mental health in this decade, but it's also important to note it can be an incredibly powerful source of motivation and inspiration to improve ourselves if we use it for the right reasons, of course. I think many times that is not always the case. Comparison actually brings with it a lot of negative impacts and it can be really, really difficult to break free from it, to stop comparing ourselves to others, often because it has nothing to do with them. It's us projecting and reflecting our own insecurities onto the image of someone else. I think this is especially common during this decade of our lives when there is so much
and it can also undermine our self-esteem, our ability to focus on ourselves, our self-worth, our mental health in this decade, but it's also important to note it can be an incredibly powerful source of motivation and inspiration to improve ourselves if we use it for the right reasons, of course. I think many times that is not always the case. Comparison actually brings with it a lot of negative impacts and it can be really, really difficult to break free from it, to stop comparing ourselves to others, often because it has nothing to do with them. It's us projecting and reflecting our own insecurities onto the image of someone else. I think this is especially common during this decade of our lives when there is so much|||它还会削弱我们在这个十年的自尊心、专注于自我的能力、自我价值感以及心理健康，但同样重要的是要注意，如果我们出于正确的目的使用它，它也可以成为激励和鼓舞我们自我提升的强大动力，当然前提是方法正确。我认为很多时候并非总是如此。比较实际上会带来许多负面影响，而且要摆脱它、停止与他人比较可能会非常、非常困难，这通常是因为这与他们无关。这是我们将自己的不安全感投射并反映在别人的形象上。我认为这在我们生活的这个十年中尤其常见，因为这里有如此多的
opportunity to compare ourselves to others, so much diversity and difference in our journeys and those of our peers and those around us. Our 20s are a really confusing decade for social comparison because I'm sure looking at your own lives, you know, you probably have friends who are at very different stages. Some of us are traveling. Others of us are having children and settling down. You know, maybe you're still finishing your studies whilst your friends are receiving promotions and buying houses. People are at so many different stages in their journey and that's always on the micro or the local scale. We cannot talk about comparison.
opportunity to compare ourselves to others, so much diversity and difference in our journeys and those of our peers and those around us. Our 20s are a really confusing decade for social comparison because I'm sure looking at your own lives, you know, you probably have friends who are at very different stages. Some of us are traveling. Others of us are having children and settling down. You know, maybe you're still finishing your studies whilst your friends are receiving promotions and buying houses. People are at so many different stages in their journey and that's always on the micro or the local scale. We cannot talk about comparison.|||机会让我们与他人进行比较，我们的旅程、同龄人以及身边人的旅程也存在着如此多的多样性和差异。对于社会比较来说，我们的20多岁是一个真正令人困惑的十年，因为我相信看看你们自己的生活，你知道，你们的朋友可能处于非常不同的阶段。我们中的一些人在旅行。另一些人则在生孩子并安顿下来。你知道，也许你还在完成学业，而你的朋友们却在升职买房。人们在人生旅程中处于如此多的不同阶段，而这总是在微观或局部规模上进行的。我们不能不谈论比较。
We can't have a discussion about social comparison without talking about social media and the abundance of potential it gives us to be constantly comparing ourselves to an idealized and artificial version of random people on the internet, people we've never met, celebrities at any time of the day at the mere opening of an app.
We can't have a discussion about social comparison without talking about social media and the abundance of potential it gives us to be constantly comparing ourselves to an idealized and artificial version of random people on the internet, people we've never met, celebrities at any time of the day at the mere opening of an app.|||我们在讨论社会比较时，不可能不谈论社交媒体，以及它为我们提供的丰富可能——只需打开一个应用程序，我们就可以在一天中的任何时间，不断地将自己与互联网上随机出现的、我们从未见过的、被理想化和虚构的陌生人或名人进行比较。
I really wanted to do this episode today because comparison and constantly comparing myself to others has been a massive problem for me recently. I have not been able to break away from it, but I have been doing some things that I think might be helpful. I'll be honest, it has definitely been exacerbated recently by the growth of this show. It's an absolutely beautiful and wonderful gift,
I really wanted to do this episode today because comparison and constantly comparing myself to others has been a massive problem for me recently. I have not been able to break away from it, but I have been doing some things that I think might be helpful. I'll be honest, it has definitely been exacerbated recently by the growth of this show. It's an absolutely beautiful and wonderful gift,|||我今天真的很想做这一集，因为比较以及不断地将自己与他人进行比较最近对我来说是一个巨大的问题。我一直无法摆脱它，但我一直在做一些我认为可能会有帮助的事情。说实话，最近随着这个节目的发展，这种情况确实加剧了。这绝对是一份美丽而绝妙的礼物，
like truly a blessing that this audience and this community of listeners has grown so much in the past few months. But on the flip side, I have also found myself constantly comparing myself to other people in the field, to other creators, whether I'm doing this right, whether I fit the mold, who's doing it differently, who's doing it better. I've definitely spent quite a few sleepless nights thinking about these things and comparing myself to other people, other podcasters, feeling like a failure like I'm doing something wrong and undergoing all of these tiny micro comparisons between me and others and then also doing that in my daily life when I walk down the street when I interact with friends when I go on social media constantly thinking to myself am I as
like truly a blessing that this audience and this community of listeners has grown so much in the past few months. But on the flip side, I have also found myself constantly comparing myself to other people in the field, to other creators, whether I'm doing this right, whether I fit the mold, who's doing it differently, who's doing it better. I've definitely spent quite a few sleepless nights thinking about these things and comparing myself to other people, other podcasters, feeling like a failure like I'm doing something wrong and undergoing all of these tiny micro comparisons between me and others and then also doing that in my daily life when I walk down the street when I interact with friends when I go on social media constantly thinking to myself am I as|||过去几个月里，这个听众群体和听众社区能够增长这么多，简直是一个真正的祝福。但另一方面，我也发现自己不断地将自己与该领域的其他人、其他创作者进行比较，思考我这样做是否正确，我是否符合这种模式，谁的做法与众不同，谁做得更好。我确实度过了好几个不眠之夜，思考这些事情，并将自己与其他人、其他播客进行比较，觉得自己像个失败者，好像做错了什么，并在自己和他人之间经历所有这些微小的比较，然后在我走在街上、与朋友互动、上社交媒体等日常生活中也是如此，脑子里总是在想：我是不是和他们一样
smart as they are why don't I look like that person why haven't I achieved as much as them why do they have everything together and I don't so here's the thing something that I've realized is that No one's judgments are as strong and powerful and impactful as our own. Our in-20s present this incredible opportunity, this incredibly formative time, to intentionally break away from constant comparison and allow ourselves to experience the freedom of caring about fewer people's opinions and reflections. So today let's break down the psychology and the science behind social comparison we're going and discuss the foundations of social comparison, why it is that we compare ourselves to others,
smart as they are why don't I look like that person why haven't I achieved as much as them why do they have everything together and I don't so here's the thing something that I've realized is that No one's judgments are as strong and powerful and impactful as our own. Our in-20s present this incredible opportunity, this incredibly formative time, to intentionally break away from constant comparison and allow ourselves to experience the freedom of caring about fewer people's opinions and reflections. So today let's break down the psychology and the science behind social comparison we're going and discuss the foundations of social comparison, why it is that we compare ourselves to others,|||聪明？为什么我长得不像那个人？为什么我没有取得和他们一样多的成就？为什么他们一切都井井有条，而我却没有？所以事情是这样的，我意识到的一点是：没有任何人的判断能像我们自己那样强烈、强大和具有影响力。我们的20多岁提供了一个不可思议的机会，一个极其重要的成长期，让我们能够刻意摆脱不断的比较，让自己体验到不再那么在意别人的看法和反应的自由。所以今天我们就来剖析社会比较背后的心理学和科学，我们要讨论社会比较的基础，为什么我们要把自己和别人作比较，
even on an unconscious level, the mechanisms behind which is influences our behaviour, as well as some of the consequences of unchecked comparison. But, of course, this show is never going to be a pity party. We're all about empowering ourselves to break out of negative patterns and behaviours and to understand the psychology behind these behaviours. So I also want to talk about how it is that we can overcome social comparison and be free of our own judgments and our own comparisons with others. So buckle in. Let's get into it. So I think a really great place to start is to kind of provide an overview of what social comparison actually is.
even on an unconscious level, the mechanisms behind which is influences our behaviour, as well as some of the consequences of unchecked comparison. But, of course, this show is never going to be a pity party. We're all about empowering ourselves to break out of negative patterns and behaviours and to understand the psychology behind these behaviours. So I want to talk about how it is that we can overcome social comparison and be free of our own judgments and our own comparisons with others. So buckle in. Let's get into it. So I think a really great place to start is to kind of provide an overview of what social comparison actually is.|||甚至在潜意识层面，影响我们行为的背后机制，以及失控比较的一些后果。但是，当然，这个节目绝不会是一场自怨自艾的诉苦会。我们致力于赋能自己，打破消极的模式和行为，并理解这些行为背后的心理学。所以我想谈谈我们如何才能克服社会比较，摆脱我们自己的判断以及与他人的比较。所以系好安全带。让我们开始吧。所以我觉得一个很好的切入点是大致概述一下什么是社会比较。
So social comparison, it's a psychological concept and it's the act of comparing our ability. our traits, our characteristics to others. We often come to judge ourselves and interpret our own self-worth by evaluating our behaviors in comparison to others to confirm whether we're doing the right thing, whether we are doing a good job. Here's the thing. We constantly evaluate ourselves across so many different domains
So social comparison, it's a psychological concept and it's the act of comparing our ability. our traits, our characteristics to others. We often come to judge ourselves and interpret our own self-worth by evaluating our behaviors in comparison to others to confirm whether we're doing the right thing, whether we are doing a good job. Here's the thing. We constantly evaluate ourselves across so many different domains|||所以社会比较，这是一个心理学概念，它是指将我们的能力、我们的特质、我们的特征与他人进行比较的行为。我们经常通过将自己的行为与他人进行比较来评估自己，从而判断自己并诠释自己的自我价值，以确认我们是否在做正确的事情，我们是否做得很好。问题是这样的。我们在如此多的不同领域中不断地评估自己，
like attractiveness, wealth, success, intelligence, the things that we have a tendency to actually define our worth by, especially in our 20s when our identities can be quite shaky and we navigate really massive live transitions and a shift into adulthood. I found this really interesting study while I was looking into this concept and looking into this episode. And it stated that as much as 10% of our thoughts, our everyday thoughts involve a comparison of some kind, which is honestly kind of horrific to think about, right? Like 10% of our everyday thoughts involve some form of social comparison. No wonder we as a society are kind of defined in many ways by our insecurities at the moment.
like attractiveness, wealth, success, intelligence, the things that we have a tendency to actually define our worth by, especially in our 20s when our identities can be quite shaky and we navigate really massive live transitions and a shift into adulthood. I found this really interesting study while I was looking into this concept and looking into this episode. And it stated that as much as 10% of our thoughts, our everyday thoughts involve a comparison of some kind, which is honestly kind of horrific to think about, right? Like 10% of our everyday thoughts involve some form of social comparison. No wonder we as a society are kind of defined in many ways by our insecurities at the moment.|||比如吸引力、财富、成功、智力，这些往往是我们用来定义自己价值的东西，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候，我们的身份可能很不稳定，我们要经历巨大的生活转变并过渡到成年期。在研究这个概念和这一集节目时，我发现了这个非常有趣的研究。它指出，我们高达10%的思想，即日常思想，都包含某种形式的比较，老实说，这想起来有点可怕，对吧？就像我们日常想法中有 10% 涉及某种形式的社会比较一样。难怪我们这个社会在很多方面目前都被我们的不安全感所定义。
I also think the statistic is actually quite invaluable in some ways in demonstrating that these thoughts, that social comparison might actually be valuable in some. some way or another, for it to be occurring at such a high frequency. Here's the thing about comparison, though. It's not a limited activity. It can honestly occur across any domain of our lives that we deem as important from what we look like, our bodies, our achievements, our grades, our performance at work, to things like how many friends we have, the clothes we wear, our ambitions.
I also think the statistic is actually quite invaluable in some ways in demonstrating that these thoughts, that social comparison might actually be valuable in some. some way or another, for it to be occurring at such a high frequency. Here's the thing about comparison, though. It's not a limited activity. It can honestly occur across any domain of our lives that we deem as important from what we look like, our bodies, our achievements, our grades, our performance at work, to things like how many friends we have, the clothes we wear, our ambitions.|||我也认为这个统计数据在某些方面非常珍贵，它表明这些想法，即社会比较，实际上可能在某种程度上具有价值，否则它不会以如此高的频率发生。然而，关于比较，情况是这样的。它不是一项受限制的活动。老实说，它会发生在我们生活中我们认为重要的任何领域，从我们的外表、身材、成就、成绩、工作表象，到我们有多少朋友、我们穿的衣服、我们的野心。
That is, I think, the most dangerous aspect of comparison. It's not an isolated social phenomena. It's really wide-reaching and can impact us in any area of life in which we might be insecure. Often it actually is the very things that we are most insecure about, that we are most likely or more likely to compare ourselves to others based on. that's because these attributes, these characteristics are at the top of our mind. They are the things that consume us and that we want validation on. So for example, if you're really insecure about your career progression, I know that's a really common one, you know, whether you're getting the right internships, whether you're pursuing
That is, I think, the most dangerous aspect of comparison. It's not an isolated social phenomena. It's really wide-reaching and can impact us in any area of life in which we might be insecure. Often it actually is the very things that we are most insecure about, that we are most likely or more likely to compare ourselves to others based on. that's because these attributes, these characteristics are at the top of our mind. They are the things that consume us and that we want validation on. So for example, if you're really insecure about your career progression, I know that's a really common one, you know, whether you're getting the right internships, whether you're pursuing|||我认为这正是比较最危险的地方。它不是一个孤立的社会现象。它的影响范围非常广泛，可能会影响我们生活中任何我们可能感到没有安全感的领域。通常，恰恰是我们最没有安全感的事情，我们最有可能或更有可能以此为基础将自己与他人进行比较。那是因为这些属性、这些特征占据了我们思维的最前端。它们是消耗我们并我们希望得到验证的事情。例如，如果你对自己的职业发展非常没有安全感，我知道这是一个非常常见的问题，你知道，你是否获得了正确的实习机会，你是否在追求
the right opportunities, whether you're going to be successful, often that is the first thing We're going to compare ourselves against when we meet a new person, you know, asking ourselves these almost implicit questions of what is this person doing that I'm not? Where do we stand in relation to each other? Valuing their successes compared to our own. This actually just makes the insecurity worse, right? And it can cause it to become much larger and much more harmful. The more we feed the beast of social comparison, the more we feed our insecurities by
the right opportunities, whether you're going to be successful, often that is the first thing We're going to compare ourselves against when we meet a new person, you know, asking ourselves these almost implicit questions of what is this person doing that I'm not? Where do we stand in relation to each other? Valuing their successes compared to our own. This actually just makes the insecurity worse, right? And it can cause it to become much larger and much more harmful. The more we feed the beast of social comparison, the more we feed our insecurities by|||正确的机会，你是否会成功，通常这是我们在遇到新朋友时首先要与之进行比较的事情，你知道，我们会问自己这些几乎是隐含的问题：这个人做了什么而我没做？我们彼此之间的相对位置在哪里？拿他们的成功与我们自己的成功进行比较。这实际上只会让不安全感变得更糟，对吧？并且会导致它变得更大、更有害。我们越是喂养社会比较这头野兽，我们越是通过以下方式喂养我们的不安全感：
comparing ourselves to others, the bigger it gets, the more fuel it needs to be satisfied, and the more of our time and our energy and our self-esteem that it takes over. It can also lead to a level of unhealthy competition between ourselves and others that can actually sabotage potentially really positive and collaborative relationships. When social comparison occurs, often our worth becomes centered and, you know, determined on how we perceive others and how we perceive ourselves and the outcome of that unconscious comparison between us. We no longer tend to view the people we meet, our peers, our friends as important contributors to our lives, but we see them as a way to judge ourselves
comparing ourselves to others, the bigger it gets, the more fuel it needs to be satisfied, and the more of our time and our energy and our self-esteem that it takes over. It can also lead to a level of unhealthy competition between ourselves and others that can actually sabotage potentially really positive and collaborative relationships. When social comparison occurs, often our worth becomes centered and, you know, determined on how we perceive others and how we perceive ourselves and the outcome of that unconscious comparison between us. We no longer tend to view the people we meet, our peers, our friends as important contributors to our lives, but we see them as a way to judge ourselves|||将自己与他人进行比较，它就会变得越大，满足它需要的燃料就越多，它占据我们的时间、精力和自尊也就越多。它还可能导致我们与他人之间产生某种程度的不健康竞争，这实际上会破坏潜在的非常积极和合作的关系。当社会比较发生时，我们的价值往往会集中并取决于我们如何看待他人以及我们如何看待自己，以及我们之间无意识比较的结果。我们不再倾向于将我们遇到的人、我们的同龄人、我们的朋友视为我们生活的重要贡献者，而是将他们视为评判我们自己的方式
and more often than not to put ourselves down. So there are actually two types of social comparison and each of them serve their own like independent function I would say so the two types are upward and downward social comparison most of the instances of comparison we think about and when we compare ourselves to others and the ones that we've discussed so far have somewhat of a negative outcome right like if we think about an example based on our material worth we might meet someone who is a lot wealthier than us who wears really nice clothes and has nice things. things and more possessions, and we're going to look at that person and see ourselves as less, see ourselves as less worthwhile. And it's probably not going to make you feel particularly great
and more often than not to put ourselves down. So there are actually two types of social comparison and each of them serve their own like independent function I would say so the two types are upward and downward social comparison most of the instances of comparison we think about and when we compare ourselves to others and the ones that we've discussed so far have somewhat of a negative outcome right like if we think about an example based on our material worth we might meet someone who is a lot wealthier than us who wears really nice clothes and has nice things. things and more possessions, and we're going to look at that person and see ourselves as less, see ourselves as less worthwhile. And it's probably not going to make you feel particularly great|||而且往往是为了贬低自己。所以实际上有两种类型的社会比较，每一种都有它们自己的独立功能，我想说的是这两种类型是向上和向下的社会比较。我们想到的大多数比较实例，以及当我们把自己和别人作比较时，以及我们到目前为止讨论过的那些，都有点消极的结果，对吧？就像如果我们考虑一个基于我们的物质价值的例子，我们可能会遇到一个比我们富有得多的人，他穿着非常漂亮的衣服，拥有美好的事物。东西和更多的财产，我们会看着那个人，觉得自己不如他，觉得自己不那么有价值。这可能不会让你感觉特别好
about yourself because this instance of social comparison has caused us to establish almost like a temporary hierarchy with this other person on the top and us on the bottom. And this essentially leads us to the belief that we are less accomplished, we are less successful. And And in these instances, we end up feeling a sense of inadequacy. We end up feeling a sense of really deep, rooted dissatisfaction. This is an instance of upward social comparison. So we compare ourselves to someone doing better than us in an area of life. So yes, I think this can create some really negative feelings and reactions that we've discussed.
about yourself because this instance of social comparison has caused us to establish almost like a temporary hierarchy with this other person on the top and us on the bottom. And this essentially leads us to the belief that we are less accomplished, we are less successful. And And in these instances, we end up feeling a sense of inadequacy. We end up feeling a sense of really deep, rooted dissatisfaction. This is an instance of upward social comparison. So we compare ourselves to someone doing better than us in an area of life. So yes, I think this can create some really negative feelings and reactions that we've discussed.|||关于你自己，因为这种社会比较导致我们建立了一个类似于临时等级制度的结构，另一个人在上面，我们在下面。这本质上导致我们相信我们成就更少，我们不太成功。在这些情况下，我们最终会感到一种不足感。我们最终会有一种非常深刻、根深蒂固的不满感。这就是向上社会比较的一个例子。所以我们将自己与在生活的某个领域做得比我们更好的人进行所以是的，我认为这会产生我们已经讨论过的一些非常消极的情绪和反应。
You know, it makes you feel inadequate, makes you feel shame. It makes you feel unfulfilled. But an important caveat is that upward social comparison can also motivate us towards self-improvement. It's not always a negative thing, as we might see it as. When we meet people who we see as better than us, as more accomplished, these people can actually serve as examples from which we model our behavior and inspire towards. It's why, you know, having positive and successful role models can be so important in our lives because we inherently compare ourselves to them. And then we perhaps attempt to emulate their behaviours. This may give us the motivation to address areas of our lives where we are naturally unsatisfied, not because of social comparison,
You know, it makes you feel inadequate, makes you feel shame. It makes you feel unfulfilled. But an important caveat is that upward social comparison can also motivate us towards self-improvement. It's not always a negative thing, as we might see it as. When we meet people who we see as better than us, as more accomplished, these people can actually serve as examples from which we model our behavior and inspire towards. It's why, you6 know, having positive and successful role models can be so important in our lives because we inherently compare ourselves to them. And then we perhaps attempt to emulate their behaviours. This may give us the motivation to address areas of our lives where we are naturally unsatisfied, not because of social comparison,|||你知道，它会让你感到不够好，让你感到羞耻。它会让你觉得不满足。但一个重要的警告是，向上的社会比较也可以激励我们进行自我提升。它并不总是像我们所看到的那样是一件消极的事情。当我们遇到我们认为比我们更好、更有成就的人时，这些人实际上可以作为我们模仿行为和追求灵感的榜样。这就是为什么，你知道，拥有积极和成功的榜样在我们的生活中如此重要，因为我们天生就会将自己与他们进行比较。然后我们可能会试图效仿他们的行为。这可能会给我们提供动力去解决我们生活中自然不满意的地方，而不是因为社会比较，
but because we innately know that we can do better for ourselves, that these people can provide us with a belief. that we can be a better version of ourselves. There is evidence that it can be done. In that way, I think social comparison can be really highly beneficial, especially when we use our social networks to push ourselves. There was this study that was done, and it found that a level of friendly competition and friendly upward social comparison was actually really effective in pushing people to exercise more often and pushing people to achieve more. because when we see someone else doing really well, it pushes us to keep up and to do more. It's known as the social racket effect.
but because we innately know that we can do better for ourselves, that these people can provide us with a belief. that we can be a better version of ourselves. There is evidence that it can be done. In that way, I think social comparison can be really highly beneficial, especially when we use our social networks to push ourselves. There was this study that was done, and it found that a level of friendly competition and friendly upward social comparison was actually really effective in pushing people to exercise more often and pushing people to achieve more. because when we see someone else doing really well, it pushes us to keep up and to do more. It's known as the social racket effect.|||而是因为我们内心里知道我们可以为自己做得更好，这些人可以为我们提供一种信念：我们可以成为更好的自己。有证据表明这是可以做到的。从这个意义上说，我认为社会比较可以是非常有益的，尤其是当我们利用我们的社交网络来推动自己时。曾有过这样一项研究，它发现一定程度的友善竞争和友善的向上社会比较，实际上在推动人们更频繁地锻炼和推动人们取得更多成就方面非常有效。因为当我们看到别人做得很好时，它会促使我们跟上并做得更多。这被称为社会球拍效应。
Each person's activity generates more activity amongst others. So social networks in which people are offered opportunities to inspire each other and given a healthy amount of competition can actually be quite helpful. The very existence and the act of upward comparison is, this confirmation that we can achieve our dreams and our desires. This links to the second type of social comparison. So the second type is downward comparison. In this instance, you compare yourself to someone who is worse off than you. In this case, this form of social comparison can contribute to almost a spike in our self-esteem, which can initially make us feel better about ourselves,
Each person's activity generates more activity amongst others. So social networks in which people are offered opportunities to inspire each other and given a healthy amount of competition can actually be quite helpful. The very existence and the act of upward comparison is, this confirmation that we can achieve our dreams and our desires. This links to the second type of social comparison. So the second type is downward comparison. In this instance, you compare yourself to someone who is worse off than you. In this case, this form of social comparison can contribute to almost a spike in our self-esteem, which can initially make us feel better about ourselves,|||每个人的活动都会在其他人中间产生更多的活动。因此，人们有机会互相激励并获得适度健康竞争的社交网络实际上是非常有帮助的。向上比较的存在和行为本身就是对我们能够实现梦想和欲望的确认。这连接到第二种类型的社会比较。所以第二种类型是向下比较。在这种情况下，你将自己与一个不如你的人进行比较。在这种情况下，这种形式的社会比较会导致我们的自尊心几乎飙升，这最初会让我们对自己感觉更好，
right? Like if we meet someone and we look at them and we're like, oh, I'm probably better than that person, of course you're going to feel great, right? But this can also contribute to a level of arrogance and a level of overconfidence as well as probably making us a little bit unbearable. It's also worth asking yourself, do you really want to be the person who only feels good about themselves and secure about themselves? If they're surrounded by people they perceive as being not as good as them, as being worse off or not as successful or talented, do you really want to derive your self-confidence from inherently and unconsciously bringing others down
right? Like if we meet someone and we look at them and we're like, oh, I'm probably better than that person, of course you're going to feel great, right? But this can also contribute to a level of arrogance and a level of overconfidence as well as probably making us a little bit unbearable. It's also worth asking yourself, do you really want to be the person who only feels good about themselves and secure about themselves? If they're surrounded by people they perceive as being not as good as them, as being worse off or not as successful or talented, do you really want to derive your self-confidence from inherently and unconsciously bringing others down|||对吧？就像如果我们遇到某个人，看着他们，心想，哦，我可能比那个人好，你当然会感觉很好，对吧？但这也会导致一定程度的傲慢和过度自信，并且可能让我们变得有点难以忍受。这也值得问问你自己，你真的想成为那种只有在周围都是他们认为不如自己、处境更糟、或者不如自己成功或有才华的人时，才会自我感觉良好、有安全感的人吗？你真的想从天生和无意识地贬低别人中获得自信吗？
so that you can feel better? So although we have discussed how social comparison can at times be a tool for self-growth and can also impact our self-esteem, especially in downward social comparison, when we're comparing ourselves to someone who we see is less successful or worse off than us. Another element of this act of constantly comparing our lives to others, whether we know that person or not, is that social comparison and the measures
so that you can feel better? So although we have discussed how social comparison can at times be a tool for self-growth and can also impact our self-esteem, especially in downward social comparison, when we're comparing ourselves to someone who we see is less successful or worse off than us. Another element of this act of constantly comparing our lives to others, whether we know that person or not, is that social comparison and the measures|||这样你才能感觉更好？因此，尽管我们已经讨论了社会比较有时如何成为自我成长的工具，并且也会影响我们的自尊，尤其是在向下社会比较中，当我们把自己与我们认为不如我们成功或处境更糟的人进行比较时。这种不断将我们的生活与他人进行比较的行为的另一个因素，无论我们是否认识那个人，就是社会比较和衡量标准
by which we compare ourselves to others are often really unrealistic. We're not very good at being unbiased judges of things and seeing things objectively. Every instance of comparison, every time you look at someone and you think, oh, I'm not as good as them. Or you look at someone and think, oh, I'm better than them. Each of these judgments is in some way influenced by our own beliefs and our beliefs about the world. We are in each of our own ways a pretty biased judge. So, for example, say you're engaging in downward social comparison with a friend. You've compared yourself to them almost unconsciously and believe in some way that perhaps you're more intelligent, that you're smarter than them.
by which we compare ourselves to others are often really unrealistic. We're not very good at being unbiased judges of things and seeing things objectively. Every instance of comparison, every time you look at someone and you think, oh, I'm not as good as them. Or you look at someone and think, oh, I'm better than them. Each of these judgments is in some way influenced by our own beliefs and our beliefs about the world. We are in each of our own ways a pretty biased judge. So, for example, say you're engaging in downward social comparison with a friend. You've compared yourself to them almost unconsciously and believe in some way that perhaps you're more intelligent, that you're smarter than them.|||我们用来将自己与他人进行比较的尺度往往是非常不切实际的。我们很不擅长做事情的不偏不倚的法官并客观地看待事物。每一次比较，每次你看着某人并心想，哦，我不如他们。或者你看着某人并心想，哦，我比他们好。这些判断中的每一个都在某种程度上受到我们自己的信仰和我们对世界的信仰的影响。在各自的方面，我们都是一个相当有偏见的法官。所以，例如，假设你正在和一个朋友进行向下的社会比较。你几乎在无意识中将自己与他们进行了比较，并且在某种程度上相信也许你更聪明，你比他们更聪明。
That judgment is entirely based on your view of the situation, and it's probably not very accurate. We don't really have any real way of knowing that for certain. We don't know the contents of this person's mind. We don't know how they solve problems, the way they think, the books they read, the discussions they have. We're basing that judgment off of our own limited knowledge of a situation, and most of the time we tend to get it wrong.
That judgment is entirely based on your view of the situation, and it's probably not very accurate. We don't really have any real way of knowing that for certain. We don't know the contents of this person's mind. We don't know how they solve problems, the way they think, the books they read, the discussions they have. We're basing that judgment off of our own limited knowledge of a situation, and most of the time we tend to get it wrong.|||这种判断完全基于你对情况的看法，而且可能不是很准确。我们真的没有任何真实的方法可以确切地知道这一点。我们不知道这个人的内心世界。我们不知道他们是如何解决问题的，他们的思维方式，他们读的书，他们进行的讨论。我们是根据自己对情况的有限了解做出这种判断的，而且大多数时候我们往往会弄错。
this also works in the opposite direction, right? When we're comparing ourselves to others and feel like we're lesser or not as accomplished or not as good, we actually don't know that. Yes, there are obviously external indicators of success, but most of the time, when we are comparing ourselves to others, that is just a reflection of what we're insecure about. It's a projection of our own fears and insecurities.
this also works in the opposite direction, right? When we're comparing ourselves to others and feel like we're lesser or not as accomplished or not as good, we actually don't know that. Yes, there are obviously external indicators of success, but most of the time, when we are comparing ourselves to others, that is just a reflection of what we're insecure about. It's a projection of our own fears and insecurities.|||这在相反的方向上也同样起作用，对吧？当我们把自己与他人进行比较并觉得我们不如别人、没有成就或不够好时，我们实际上并不知道这一点。是的，显然存在成功的外部指标，但大多数时候，当我们把自己与他人进行比较时，那只是我们缺乏安全感的反映。这是我们自己的恐惧和不安全感的投射。
it's important to remind ourselves social comparison is not the truth. It is not completely factual. It's based on our own perception of others and our own perception of ourselves. So why does this happen? What is it about social comparison that makes the habit so hard to break? Well, that's our crucial question for the day, right? Why does this happen? Why do we find ourselves in this constant cycle of social comparison for better,
this is important to remind ourselves social comparison is not the truth. It is not completely factual. It's based on our own perception of others and our own perception of ourselves. So why does this happen? What is it about social comparison that makes the habit so hard to break? Well, that's our crucial question for the day, right? Why does this happen? Why do we find ourselves in this constant cycle of social comparison for better,|||这一点很重要，我们要提醒自己，社会 comparison 并不是真相。它并不完全是事实。它基于我们自己对他人的感知以及我们对自己本身的感知。那么为什么会这样呢？社会比较有什么特点让这种习惯如此难以打破？好吧，这就是我们今天至关重要的问题，对吧？为什么会这样？为什么我们会发现自己陷入这种不断的社会比较循环中，无论是好是坏，
or for worse. While social psychology can actually explain quite a bit of this, social comparison as toxic and dangerous as it can be when it's out of control, it's actually a fairly normal behavioural strategy that we use to better understand our social standing, our status, and to mediate and control our behaviours to be appropriate. So when we compare ourselves to others to understand our behaviour, we also get a sense of gauging how we're doing. in life and whether we are fitting in and this has an evolutionary function we want to remain part of the in-group we want to remain part of the pack part of the tribe and a way that we do this is compare ourselves to other members of a similar group and judge our behavior to see if we're
or for worse. While social psychology can actually explain quite a bit of this, social comparison as toxic and dangerous as it can be when it's out of control, it's actually a fairly normal behavioural strategy that we use to better understand our social standing, our status, and to mediate and control our behaviours to be appropriate. So when we compare ourselves to others to understand our behaviour, we also get a sense of gauging how we're doing. in life and whether we are fitting in and this has an evolutionary function we want to remain part of the in-group we want to remain part of the pack part of the tribe and a way that we do this is compare ourselves to other members of a similar group and judge our behavior to see if we're|||还是更糟。虽然社会心理学实际上可以解释很大一部分原因，但社会比较在失控时可能具有毒性和危险性，但它实际上是一种相当正常的行为策略，我们用它来更好地理解我们的社会地位、身份，并调节和控制我们的行为以使其恰当。因此，当我们通过与他人进行比较来理解自己的行为时，我们也会有一种衡量我们在生活中表现如何以及我们是否融入其中的感觉，这具有一种进化功能：我们希望保持内群体的一部分，我们希望保持群体的一部分，部落的一部分，而我们做到这一点的方法就是将自己与类似群体的其他成员进行比较，并判断我们的行为，看看我们是否
fitting in how we're doing if we're meeting the social norms and the social mold although it may feel like it social comparison it's not done at random. Think about when you're on the train or at the airport. You're not comparing yourself to, you know, the six-year-old man with a wife and children. Often you're comparing yourself to people of your own age, people of a similar type and characteristic to you in some way. That's because we tend to compare ourselves to people that have similar attributes that are close to our own. The more similarities we have with people, the worse our level of social comparison is likely to be. and ultimately the more useful our minds might find that.
fitting in how we're doing if we're meeting the social norms and the social mold although it may feel like it social comparison it's not done at random. Think about when you're on the train or at the airport. You're not comparing yourself to, you're know, the six-year-old man with a wife and children. Often you're comparing yourself to people of your own age, people of a similar type and characteristic to you in some way. That's Because we tend to compare ourselves to people that have similar attributes that are close to our own. The more similarities we have with people, the worse our level of social comparison is likely to be. and ultimately the more useful our minds might find that.|||融入其中，我们的表现如何，我们是否符合社会规范和社会模具，尽管感觉上如此，但社会比较并不是随机进行的。想想当你坐火车或在机场时。你不会把自己和那个带着妻子孩子的六十岁男人进行比较，你知道的。通常，你会把自己和与你同龄的人进行比较，在某种程度上与你有相似类型和特征的人。那是因为我们倾向于将自己与具有与我们自己的属性相似的属性的人进行比较。我们与人们的相似之处越多，我们的社会比较水平可能就越糟糕。最终，我们的思维可能会觉得这更有用。
I'm just going to break that down a little bit more. So there's no point comparing yourself to someone who's, you know, 30, 40 years older than you because the way that they act might not be the way that you should act. The way that they are, what they're doing might not be what you should be doing. So instead, our brains get us to compare ourselves to people who are more similar to us because our brains from an evolutionary perspective find that information, more valuable. I think it's important though to bring us back to reality here and reiterate what we were speaking about before, which is that our judgments, no matter how inherent they are, no matter how
I'm just going to break that down a little bit more. So there's no point comparing yourself to someone who's, you know, 30, 40 years older than you because the way that they act might not be the way that you should act. The way that they are, what they're doing might not be what you should be doing. So instead, our brains get us to compare ourselves to people who are more similar to us because our brains from an evolutionary perspective find that information, more valuable. I think it's important though to bring us back to reality here and reiterate what we were speaking about before, which is that our judgments, no matter how inherent they are, no matter how|||我再稍微分解一下。所以把自己和一个比你大30、40岁的人进行比较是没有意义的，因为他们的行事方式可能不是你该有的行事方式。他们的为人，他们正在做的事情可能不是你该做的事情。相反，我们的大脑促使我们把自己与更相似的人进行比较，因为从进化的角度来看，我们的大脑发现这些信息更有价值。不过我认为，把我们带回现实并重申我们之前所讨论的内容是很重要的，那就是我们的判断，无论它们多么根深蒂固，无论它们如何
biologically or evolutionarily natural they may feel, they're actually incredibly flawed, and they're not based on the whole truth. When we're unable to recognize this, when we're unable to realize that we are quite biased and we use social comparison as a means to bring ourselves down, we can fall into that cycle, that spiral of never feeling good enough, never feeling like we fit in or that we have value compared to other people in our lives. This is one of the less helpful aspects of social comparison, the ones we often recognize, that's when they rear their head. The impact of social comparison, it's obviously going to vary based on what insecurity it's playing into, but mainly what we end up seeing is a sense of shame, a lower self-esteem,
biologically or evolutionarily natural they may feel, they're actually incredibly flawed, and they're not based on the whole truth. When we're unable to recognize this, when we're unable to realize that we are quite biased and we use social comparison as a means to bring ourselves down, we can fall into that cycle, that spiral of never feeling good enough, never feeling like we fit in or that we have value compared to other people in our lives. This is one of the less helpful aspects of social comparison, the ones we often recognize, that's when they rear their head. The impact of social comparison, it's obviously going to vary based on what insecurity it's playing into, but mainly what we end up seeing is a sense of shame, a lower self-esteem,|||在生物学或进化上感觉多么自然，它们实际上都极其有缺陷，并且并非基于全部真相。当我们无法认识到这一点时，当我们无法意识到我们相当偏颇并利用社会比较作为贬低自己的手段时，我们就会陷入那个循环，那个永远觉得自己不够好，永远觉得自己与生活中的其他人相比无法融入或没有价值的螺旋。这是社会比较中较没有帮助的方面之一，也是我们经常认识到的方面，这就是它们抬头的时候。社会比较的影响显然会根据它所利用的不安全感而有所不同，但主要我们最终看到的是羞耻感、更低的自尊心、
fewer positive statements about ourselves, negative language towards ourselves, and a sense that we need to conform or change something about ourselves, often in a drastic way. It's really exhausting, I will say, it's really exhausting, spending our waking hours, comparing ourselves to others, and performing this mental calculation about where we stand, about who's doing things better than us. Yeah, it's really tiring, and it can be really hard to break out of. I mentioned this at the beginning, but I do believe, and a lot of the research confirms as well, that this is often made worse by the prominence of social media. Social comparison, it becomes unavoidable in this environment and even more severe and unrealistic
fewer positive statements about ourselves, negative language towards ourselves, and a sense that we need to conform or change something about ourselves, often in a drastic way. It's really exhausting, I will say, it's really exhausting, spending our waking hours, comparing ourselves to others, and performing this mental calculation about where we stand, about who's doing things better than us. Yeah, it's really tiring, and it can be really hard to break out of. I mentioned this at the beginning, but I do believe, and a lot of the research confirms as well, that this is often made worse by the prominence of social media. Social comparison, it becomes unavoidable in this environment and even more severe and unrealistic|||对自己更少的积极评价、对自己消极的语言，以及一种我们需要顺应或改变自己某些方面的感觉，通常是以一种激烈的方式。我要说的是，这真的很累，真的很累，花我们清醒的时间把自己和别人比较，并进行这种精神计算，关于我们站在哪里，关于谁做的事情比我们更好。是的，这真的很累，而且很难摆脱。我在开始时提到过这一点，但我确实相信，许多研究也证实了这一点，这种情况往往因社交媒体的突出而变得更糟。社交 comparison，在这种环境中变得不可避免，甚至更严重和不切实际
because when we post on social media, we're performing for an audience. We're putting forward an idealized and fake version of our lives. I feel like I don't need to say that social media is not real life, right? Like most of us know that, but it can be really hard to remember that consciously, especially when we are constantly exposed to this almost like torrential flooding of information around and beautiful bodies and perfect lives. It's really hard to remind ourselves that that's not real. No one sees the tears behind what is maybe a perfect relationship or the insecurity
because when we post on social media, we're performing for an audience. We're putting forward an idealized and fake version of our lives. I feel like I don't need to say that social media is not real life, right? Like most of us know that, but it can be really hard to remember that consciously, especially when we are constantly exposed to this almost like torrential flooding of information around and beautiful bodies and perfect lives. It's really hard to remind ourselves that that's not real. No one sees the tears behind what is maybe a perfect relationship or the insecurity|||因为当我们在社交媒体上发帖时，我们是在为观众表演。我们展示的是我们生活中理想化和虚假的版本。我觉得我不需要说社交媒体不是现实生活，对吧？就像我们大多数人都知道的那样，但要有意识地记住这一点可能真的很难，尤其是当我们不断接触到这种几乎呈滔滔洪水般涌来的周围信息、美好的身材和完美的生活时。真的很难提醒自己那不是真的。没有人看到可能是完美关系背后的眼泪，也没有人看到不安全感
behind someone's dream body or someone's successful future. No one sees the hard work. No one sees the sacrifice. no one sees the hard, hard days. All we are seeing is the highlight reel. But our brains, they're not very good at being realistic about that and acknowledging it. Recent studies have shown that social media really encourages unhelpful social comparison, particularly upward social comparison.
behind someone's dream body or someone's successful future. No one sees the hard work. No one sees the sacrifice. no one sees the hard, hard days. All we are seeing is the highlight reel. But our brains, they're not very good at being realistic about that and acknowledging it. Recent studies have shown that social media really encourages unhelpful social comparison, particularly upward social comparison.|||隐藏在某人梦想中的身材或某人成功的未来背后。没有人看到艰苦的工作。没有人看到牺牲。没有人看到艰难的日子。我们看到的只是高光时刻。但我们的大脑并不擅长对此保持现实并承认这一点。最近的研究表明，社交媒体确实鼓励无益的社会比较，特别是向上的社会比较。
And it can reduce our overall self-esteem. But being educated about how this process occurs, why it is that we compare and contrast ourselves to others, and consciously noting when we find ourselves slipping into unhelpful comparisons can be incredibly useful and incredibly powerful. So let's discuss how we can kind of break away from social comparison and use it for good, leverage this behaviour and this mental activity to inspire us rather than bring us down. So these next few kind of like lessons, I guess, or activities, they're things that I've personally done recently, especially as I've been struggling quite a bit with social comparison.
And it can reduce our overall self-esteem. But being educated about how this process occurs, why it is that we compare and contrast ourselves to others, and consciously noting when we find ourselves slipping into unhelpful comparisons can be incredibly useful and incredibly powerful. So let's discuss how we can kind of break away from social comparison and use it for good, leverage this behaviour and this mental activity to inspire us rather than bring us down. So these next few kind of like lessons, I guess, or activities, they're things that I've personally done recently, especially as I've been struggling quite a bit with social comparison.|||并且它会降低我们的整体自尊。但了解这个过程是如何发生的，为什么我们将自己与他人进行比较和对照，并有意识地注意到我们发现自己陷入无益的比较中时，可能会非常有用且非常强大。因此，让我们讨论如何才能摆善用社会比较，利用这种行为和这种心理活动来激励我们，而不是让我们沮丧。所以接下来的这几堂课，我想，或者说活动，是我最近亲自做的事情，特别是我一直在为社会比较而苦苦挣扎的时候。
These are just things that have helped me, that the evidence suggests might help you as well, especially as someone in my 20s who's witnessing so many people at various stages in their lives. It's important to remind myself really gently that the story isn't over. This is not my final destination. This is not your final destination either. When I compare myself to others, what I'm really doing is comparing a point in my journey with a completely different point in someone else's journey. And often, my assessment of that situation isn't entirely accurate.
These are just things that have helped me, that the evidence suggests might help you as well, especially as someone in my 20s who's witnessing so many people at various stages in their lives. It's important to remind myself really gently that the story isn't over. This is not my final destination. This is not your final destination either. When I compare myself to others, what I'm really doing is comparing a point in my journey with a completely different point in someone's journey. And often, my assessment of that situation isn't entirely accurate.|||这些只是帮助过我的事情，证据表明它们也可能对你有所帮助，特别作为一名20多岁的人，我目睹了这么多人处于他们人生的不同阶段。温柔地提醒自己故事还没有结束，这很重要。这不是我的最终目的地。这也不是你的最终目的地。当我把自己和别人比较时，我真正做的是把我旅程中的一个点和别人旅程中的一个完全不同的点进行比较。而且通常，我对那种情况的评估并不完全准确。
I have no way of knowing what's going on behind the scenes. The stress, the insecurities that someone may be dealing with. All I can do is kind of focus on my situation. It might even be that this person's looking at me or at you and thinking that you've got it all together. The only thing we can really focus on is how we feel and how we behave and whether we're happy and satisfied. That is the only thing within our control, not their actions, not someone else's successes, not someone else's traits or attitudes. I think you're allowed to be selfish when it comes to this and say, you know, I come first, Like, I'm allowed to feel good about myself.
I have no way of knowing what's going on behind the scenes. The stress, the insecurities that someone may be dealing with. All I can do is kind of focus on my situation. It might even be that this person's looking at me or at you and thinking that you've got it all together. The only thing we can really focus on is how we feel and how we behave and whether we're happy and satisfied. That is the only thing within our control, not their actions, not someone else's successes, not someone else's traits or attitudes. I think you're allowed to be selfish when it comes to this and say, you know, I come first, Like, I'm allowed to feel good about myself.|||我无从得知幕后发生了什么。某人可能正在应对的压力和不安全感。我能做的就是专注于我自己的情况。甚至可能是这个人看着我或看着你，觉得你一切都掌握在手中。我们真正能关注的只有我们的感受、我们的行为以及我们是否快乐和满足。那是唯一在我们掌控之中的事情，而不是他们的行动，不是别人的成功，不是别人的特质或态度。我认为在这方面你是被允许自私的，可以说，你知道，我排在第一位，就像，我被允许对自己感觉良好一样。
I'm allowed to feel valuable. And I think it's also important to acknowledge that statement from before. Often, the things we compare ourselves based on are really a projection of our own unheeled insecurities. So taking time to really decipher why it is that you feel the need to compare yourself on these attributes, rather than seeing the whole picture, is going to be really valuable. allowing yourself to see yourself as a valuable person, that you have strengths. Our 20s are an important time to develop self-awareness, and we can leverage this insane cognitive growth that we're going to,
I'm allowed to feel valuable. And I think it's also important to acknowledge that statement from before. Often, the things we compare ourselves based on are really a projection of our own unheeled insecurities. So taking time to really decipher why it is that you feel the need to compare yourself on these attributes, rather than seeing the whole picture, is going to be really valuable. allowing yourself to see yourself as a valuable person, that you have strengths. Our 20s are an important time to develop self-awareness, and we can leverage this insane cognitive growth that we're going to,|||我被允许觉得自己很有价值。我认为同样重要的是要承认之前的那个陈述。通常，我们赖以进行比较的事物实际上是我们自己未治愈的不安全感的投射。因此，花时间真正弄清楚为什么你觉得有必要在这些属性上将自己与他人进行比较，而不是看到全貌，将是非常有价值的。让自己看到自己是一个有价值的人，你拥有优势。我们的20多岁是培养自我意识的重要时期，我们可以利用我们正在经历的这种疯狂的认知增长，
to participate in some of the hard work and on some of our deeply rooted insecurities. Also, sometimes you just need to call yourself out, particularly when you're engaging in downward social comparison, and diminishing your own self-worth. Focus on your strengths. Write them down. Use comparison as a source of inspiration. Instead of seeing people as competition,
to participate in some of the hard work and on some of our deeply rooted insecurities. Also, sometimes you just need to call yourself out, particularly when you're engaging in downward social comparison, and diminishing your own self-worth. Focus on your strengths. Write them down. Use comparison as a source of inspiration. Instead of seeing people as competition,|||去参与一些艰苦的工作，并解决我们一些根深蒂固的不安全感。此外，有时你只需要大声指出自己的问题，特别是当你参与向下的社会比较并贬低你自己的自我价值时。专注于你的优势。把它们写下来。把比较作为灵感的源泉。不要把人们视为竞争对手，
think about what they can teach you, what it is about their life that you find inspiring, that you find desirable. I think if you find a particular person or a particular profile as well across social media can be a trigger for you or a source of negative social comparison, there's a really easy way to get rid of that constant kind of sense of contrasting and judging your actions.
think about what they can teach you, what it is about their life that you find inspiring, that you find desirable. I think if you find a particular person or a particular profile as well across social media can be a trigger for you or a source of negative social comparison, there's a really easy way to get rid of that constant kind of sense of contrasting and judging your actions.|||想想他们能教给你什么，他们生活中的什么让你觉得鼓舞人心，让你觉得令人向往。我认为，如果你发现社交媒体上的某个人或某个特定个人资料可能会成为你的诱因或负面社会比较的来源，有一种非常简单的方法可以摆脱那种不断对比和评判你行为的感觉。
And that's just to cull. Time to get rid of them. Life is too short and we certainly don't need any more reasons to bring ourselves down. Make a conscious decision to create an environment, whether it is online or in person, that makes you feel valid and makes you feel worthwhile. If there's someone on social media who is like gorgeous and you're constantly looking at, you know, bikini photos of, or photos of their life or photos of all their travels and feeling bad about yourself, like you actually have a choice to not expose yourself to that. And if that's going to help you, you should do it. You really should. Like there's no reason to feel ashamed. Like if it's something that upsets you, I think it's well within your rights to kind of limit your exposure to it. The other thing I've done recently was I stopped focusing. on my own personal attributes so much. And I focused on the other amazing things in my life. I focused on practicing gratitude. I know it sounds a bit wishy-washy, but my really good friend, Zoe, she actually suggested this to me about a year ago, this like amazing tip when I was going through
And that's just to cull. Time to get rid of them. Life is too short and we certainly don't need any more reasons to bring ourselves down. Make a conscious decision to create an environment, whether it is online or in person, that makes you feel valid and makes you feel worthwhile. If there's someone on social media who is like gorgeous and you're constantly looking at, you know, bikini photos of, or photos of their life or photos of all their travels and feeling bad about yourself, like you actually have a choice to not expose yourself to that. And if that's going to help you, you should do it. You really should. Like there's no reason to feel ashamed. Like if it's something that upsets you, I think it's well within your rights to kind of limit your exposure to it. The other thing I've done recently was I stopped focusing. on my own personal attributes so much. And I focused on the other amazing things in my life. I focused on practicing gratitude. I know it sounds a bit wishy-washy, but my really good friend, Zoe, she actually suggested this to me about a year ago, this like amazing tip when I was going through|||那就是剔除。是时候摆脱它们了。生命太短暂了，我们当然不需要任何更多的理由来贬低自己。做出有意识的决定，创造一个环境，无论是在网上还是现实中，都能让你觉得自己是合理的，让你觉得自己是有价值的。如果社交媒体上有人非常华丽，而你一直在看他们的比基尼照片，或者他们生活的照片，或者他们所有旅行的照片，并对自己的感觉不好，就像你实际上可以选择不让自己接触到那样。如果这会有所帮助，你应该这样做。你真的应该这样做。就像没有理由感到羞耻一样。如果这是让你心烦意乱的事情，我认为你完全有权利限制你接触它的程度。我最近做的另一件事是，我不再那么关注我自己的个人属性了。我专注于我生活中其他神奇的事情。我专注于练习感恩。我知道这听起来有点虚无缥缈，但我非常好的朋友佐伊大约在一年前向我提出了这个建议，当我经历时，这是一个非常棒的秘诀
a really rough time. And the amount of different elements of my life that it's helped me with, It's actually ridiculous. I tell everyone to do this. Every day, before you go to bed, we all have two minutes. Just two minutes to list five things you're grateful for. I know I've mentioned this in so many episodes, but I'm going to keep saying it because it's such a game changer. No matter how harsh you've been on yourself that day,
a really rough time. And the amount of different elements of my life that it's helped me with, It's actually ridiculous. I tell everyone to do this. Every day, before you go to bed, we all have two minutes. Just two minutes to list five things you're grateful for. I know I've mentioned this in so many episodes, but I'm going to keep saying it because it's such a game changer. No matter how harsh you've been on yourself that day,|||一段非常艰难的时期。它帮助了我生活中如此多的不同元素，这实际上太荒谬了。我告诉每个人都这样做。每天睡觉前，我们所有人都有两分钟。只需两分钟，列出你感激的五件事。我知道我在很多集里都提到过这一点，但我会一直说下去，因为这是一个真正的改变游戏规则的人。无论那天你对自己的要求多么苛刻，
you can always find just five things that bring you joy. And it allows you to stop being so internally focused. and concentrate on what you have rather than what you're lacking. Commit yourself to this practice. Really just give it a go. You have nothing to lose, I promise you, it's such a game changer. And these are just some of the things that have really worked for me. And if you want to give them a try, I would really recommend it.
you can always find just five things that bring you joy. And it allows you to stop being so internally focused. and concentrate on what you have rather than what you're lacking. Commit yourself to this practice. Really just give it a go. You have nothing to lose, I promise you, it's such a game changer. And these are just some of the things that have really worked for me. And if you want to give them a try, I would really recommend it.|||你总是能找到五件能给你带来快乐的事情。它能让你停止过度关注内心。并专注于你所拥有的，而不是你所缺乏的。致力于这种做法。真的去试试吧。你没有什么可失去的，我向你保证，这是一个改变游戏规则的方法。这些只是真正对我起作用的一些事情。如果你想尝试一下，我强烈推荐它。
Please also contribute your own, share your own thoughts on this. I think it's so valuable to acknowledge how common it is in our 20s to compare ourselves to others, to think we're not doing enough, to think we're not good enough. But we can always refocus this comparison and use it as a strength. Use it for motivation to embrace the competition to inspire us. Thank you so much for listening to this episode. A bit shorter than usual, I know, but I thought we'd keep it short and sweet. It was so interesting to research this.
Please also contribute your own, share your own thoughts on this. I think it's so valuable to acknowledge how common it is in our 20s to compare ourselves to others, to think we're not doing enough, to think we're not good enough. But we can always refocus this comparison and use it as a strength. Use it for motivation to embrace the competition to inspire us. Thank you so much for listening to this episode. A bit shorter than usual, I know, but I thought we'd keep it short and sweet. It was so interesting to research this.|||也请贡献你自己的想法，分享你对此的看法。我认为承认在20多岁时将自己与他人进行比较是多么普遍，认为自己做得不够，认为自己不够好，是多么有价值的事情。但我们总是可以重新聚焦这种比较，并将其作为一种优势。用它作为动力去拥抱竞争来激励我们。非常感谢收听这一集。我知道比平时短了一点，但我认为我们还是保持简短精炼吧。研究这个太有趣了。
I'm being quite honest, this has been really something on my mind recently. It's really kind of been something I've been struggling. with so I found it really valuable to understand why it is that it happens and to kind of stop beating myself up about it because it is unconscious it is really really normal I hope that's something you brought away from this episode and if you are dealing with social comparison if you're finding yourself comparing yourself to others you're not alone I promise you know you're in a boat with many other people if you know the studies are right probably everyone everyone is doing this every moment of
I'm being quite honest, this has been really something on my mind recently. It's really kind of been something I've been struggling. with so I found it really valuable to understand why it is that it happens and to kind of stop beating myself up about it because it is unconscious it is really really normal I hope that's something you brought away from this episode and if you are dealing with social comparison if you're finding yourself comparing yourself to others you're not alone I promise you know you're in a boat with many other people if you know the studies are right probably everyone everyone is doing this every moment of|||坦白说，这确实是我最近一直在想的事情。这真的是我一直在苦苦挣扎的事情，所以我发现理解它为什么会发生，并停止为此自责是非常有价值的，因为它是无意识的，它真的非常非常正常。我希望这是你从这一集中带走的东西，如果你正在处理社会比较，如果你发现自己在和别人比较，你并不孤单，我向你保证，你知道你和其他许多人坐在一艘船上，如果你知道研究是正确的，可能每个人，每个人都在每一刻做这件事
with their lives. So you're a valuable person. You are a worthwhile person and you are doing great things. So thank you for listening as well, I guess, if you've made it this far. And if you enjoyed this episode, if you found it valuable, please feel free to leave it a five-star review if you feel cool to do so on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you are listening. Make sure to follow if you'd like to. And give us a follow on Instagram as well at That Psychology Podcast. I often put up like some little polls every now and again for the audience to decide what to listen to. So if that's something you'd like to contribute to, you have the option. And thank you again for listening.
用他们的生命。所以你是一个宝贵的人。你是一个有价值的人，你在做伟大的事情。所以我想也谢谢你们的聆听，如果你能坚持到现在的话。如果你喜欢这一集，如果你觉得它有价值，如果你愿意的话，请随时在 Spotify、Apple Podcasts 或你正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你愿意的话，请务必关注。也可以在 Instagram 上关注我们，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。我经常会为观众发布一些小投票，让大家决定听什么内容。如果你想为此做出贡献，你有这个选择。再次感谢你们的聆听。
We will be back next week with a new episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange model. and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come
我们下周将带着新的一集回归。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了精神韧性、健康以及在我们这个奇怪的模型中建立韧性的科学，以及担忧。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会脱胎换骨
out on the other side a happier more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the look back at it podcast. From 1979, that was
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 2%（即 TWA%）。在 Look Back At It 播客中。从 1979 年开始，那是
a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
对我来说的一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere.
那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back At It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话。
but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界表明，你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉利斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。